Hey, Alex!
嘿，亚历克斯！
Remember those legendary freezer pops from childhood summers?
还记得童年夏天那些传奇的冰柜汽水吗？
You know the one I'm talking about.
你知道我正在谈论的那个人。
The red, white, and blue ones.
有红的、白的、蓝的。
It is the only thing I remember from childhood.
这是我从小到大唯一记得的事情。
That's right.
这是正确的。
They pretty much ruled the neighborhood pools and playgrounds.
他们几乎统治着附近的游泳池和游乐场。
Your face should be covered with your finger.
你的脸应该用手指遮住。
It was just a delightful summer memory.
这只是一个愉快的夏日记忆。
Well, five-hour energy has taken that iconic nostalgia and reimagined it as a bold, refreshing, freeze energy shot every single sip delivers a massive flavor explosion like the original pops of which you speak expertly blending juicy cherry citrusy lime and sweet blue raspberry to completely ignite your taste buds it's that fruity taste that you crave created with zero sugar so you can enjoy the full experience guilt-free.
嗯，五小时能量将这种标志性的怀旧情绪重新想象成一种大胆、清爽、冻结的能量，每一口都能带来巨大的风味爆炸，就像你所说的原始流行音乐一样，熟练地混合多汁的樱桃、柑橘酸橙和甜美的蓝色覆盆子，完全点燃你的味蕾，这是你渴望的零糖创造的果味味道，这样你就可以毫无愧疚地享受完整的体验。
Whether you're conquering a packed schedule, tackling a mid-afternoon slump at your desk, head it out on a weekend road trip or just looking to spark a vibrant new flavor sensation.
无论您是要克服繁忙的日程、解决下午在办公桌前的困倦、周末公路旅行还是只是想激发一种充满活力的新风味感觉。
This portable shot is the perfect daily companion.
这款便携式镜头是完美的日常伴侣。
Give your routine an exciting upgrade with a mouthwatering twist on a timeless favorite.
为您的日常生活带来令人兴奋的升级，为永恒的最爱带来令人垂涎的变化。
Ignite your taste buds with a firework freeze- flavored five-hour energy shot now available online at fivehourenergy.com or or Amazon.
现在，您可以在 Fivehourenergy.com 或 Amazon 上购买烟花冷冻口味的五小时能量饮料，点燃您的味蕾。
no fuss, you know, I just need to feed myself and get some energy so I can get back to parenting.
不用大惊小怪，你知道，我只需要养活自己并获得一些能量，这样我就可以回去养育孩子了。
Yes.
是的。
And so what would solve that problem?
那么什么可以解决这个问题呢？
I'm going to steer you towards an outcome and the outcome is this product you're about to mention.
我将引导您走向一个结果，而这个结果就是您将要提到的这款产品。
Oh, oh, wait, are you talking about the, are you talking about Bavarian meets Lil Lann Yeager Snacksticks?
哦，哦，等等，你是在谈论巴伐利亚遇见 Lil Lann Yeager 零食吗？
We agreed.
我们同意了。
That's right before we started talking to Zoe said that's what we're going to talk about.
就在我们开始与佐伊交谈之前，她说这就是我们要谈论的内容。
Well, this is what I want to talk about.
嗯，这就是我想讲的。
The great tasting Bavarian meets Lil Lann Yeager Snacksticks.
美味的巴伐利亚风味与 Lil Lann Yeager 零食棒相遇。
They sent us some of these, and they are delicious, and they solve the central problem of my life, which is I forget to eat.
他们给我们送了一些，它们很美味，它们解决了我生活中的核心问题，那就是我忘记吃饭。
They're naturally fermented, they're made with real ingredients, slow smoked for bold flavor packed with 9 grams of protein per serving, and have zero sugar and zero carbs.
它们是自然发酵的，采用真正的原料制成，缓慢熏制，味道浓郁，每份含有 9 克蛋白质，并且零糖和零碳水化合物。
Also, I have a 19 year old boy, also a good moment to get a bunch of this product because he will eat us out of house and home, and he loves this stuff.
另外，我有一个 19 岁的男孩，也是购买一堆这种产品的好时机，因为他会在家里和家里吃掉我们，而且他喜欢这些东西。
It's so great.
太棒了。
grateful we got, we got to sample this.
我们很感激，我们必须品尝这个。
My son is going to eat it all.
我儿子要把它全部吃掉。
I'm going to have like none of it.
我什么都不会。
But okay, it's a snack that keeps up with your day, whether you're racing between meetings or feeding babies or 19-year-olds, doing school drop-off, just trying to finish your to-do list, take a moment to savor something delicious for you or your children.
但没关系，它是一种适合你一天的零食，无论你是在赶会议还是喂婴儿或 19 岁的孩子，送学，只是想完成你的待办事项清单，花点时间为你或你的孩子品尝美味的东西。
And did we mention they're portable, toss a few in your glove box, your gym bag, the diaper bag, wherever.
我们是否提到过它们是便携式的，可以在您的手套箱、健身包、尿布包等任何地方放一些。
We have a diaper bag.
我们有一个尿布袋。
I bet you do.
我打赌你会的。
Two or three of those bad boys.
两三个坏男孩。
Pick up a pack today, your local grocer, or stock up at bavarianmeats.com slash podcast.
立即从当地杂货店购买一包，或在 bavarianmeats.com 斜线播客上购买。
Use code mother 10, mother 10, at checkout for 10% off your first order.
结账时使用代码 mother 10, mother 10，首次订单可享受 10% 折扣。
The variant meat snack, sticks, great taste, zero sugar.
变种肉零食，棒，味道好，零糖。
Yeah, I gotta go back and grab something from the pilot because I realized after we finished taping that one of my favorite lines and moments in the pilot that Ted got to say, I forgot to mention.
是的，我得回去从试播集里拿点东西，因为在我们录制完试播集里我最喜欢的台词和时刻之一，特德说过，我忘了提及。
And it's when he's talking to Yasmeen and he says, not like a sit-around all day fantasizing about my wedding.
当他和亚斯明谈话时，他说，不像是整天坐着幻想我的婚礼。
And then he goes into this whole very specific fantasy about his wedding, which he ends with, ban no DJ.
然后他进入了关于他的婚礼的整个非常具体的幻想，他以“不禁止 DJ”结束。
People will dance.
人们会跳舞。
I'm not going to worry about it, right?
我不会担心的，对吧？
And I loved the phrase, people will dance.
我喜欢这句话，人们会跳舞。
Like as a notion of like, I'm not going to worry about it.
就像作为一个“喜欢”的概念一样，我不会担心它。
It became shorthand in my life.
它成了我生活中的速记。
The woman that I was seeing when And I got how I met your mother who worked on the audition sides with me.
我当时见到的那个女人 我知道了我是如何认识你母亲的，她和我一起在试镜方面工作。
She was Eastern European and she found that also so charming.
她是东欧人，她发现这也很迷人。
And our mantra was, and she would say it in this accent that was adorable to meet people with dance.
我们的口头禅是，她会用这种与跳舞的人见面很可爱的口音说出来。
I'm not going to worry about it.
我不会为此担心。
Like, it'll take care of itself.
就像，它会照顾自己。
And I named my corporation, people will dance.
我命名我的公司，人们会跳舞。
It really became this mantra of, remember when I said all people want to be told is it's going to be okay?
这真的成​​为了这句口头禅，还记得我说过所有人都想被告知一切都会好起来的吗？
Yes.
是的。
For me, the phrase people will dance is that it's still that in my head, like people will dance.
对我来说，人们会跳舞这个词仍然在我的脑海里，就像人们会跳舞一样。
Like people are going to have a good time.
就像人们会度过愉快的时光一样。
You don't have to micromanage every last bit of life or this evening or whatever.
你不必对生活的最后一点、今晚的事或其他什么事情进行微观管理。
So that, to me, I suppose if I was getting a phrase from how I met a other tattooed, I don't have any tattoos, but people from the world all over the world get to how I met your mother tattoos.
所以，对我来说，我想如果我从我如何遇见另一个纹身中得到一句话，我没有任何纹身，但来自世界各地的人们都知道我如何遇见你母亲纹身。
I've seen a lot of how I met your mother tattoos.
我见过很多关于我如何遇见你母亲的纹身。
If I were getting one, it would probably be people who will dance.
如果我得到一个，那可能是会跳舞的人。
Hey, welcome to a very special bonus episode of How We Made Your Mother.
嘿，欢迎收看《我们如何创造了你的母亲》的非常特别的奖励剧集。
This is an episode we call General Questions.
这是我们称之为“一般问题”的一集。
General questions.
一般问题。
I'm Josh Radder.
我是乔什·雷德。
I am here with, who am I here with?
我和谁在这里？
You're here with Craig Thomas.
你和克雷格·托马斯在一起。
Craig Thomas, the co-creator of How We Made Your Mother and our friend Alec Lev.
克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）是《我们如何造就你的母亲》的共同创作者，也是我们的朋友亚历克·列夫（Alec Lev）。
And we're going to burn through some reader mail, harkening back to Carter and Craig's origins of doing the letterman reader mail.
我们将烧掉一些读者邮件，回顾一下卡特和克雷格处理莱特曼读者邮件的起源。
We should back it up for a second.
我们应该支持一下。
I already didn't say that the running joke on how much one there doesn't start to season two.
我已经没有说过关于有多少人的笑话不会在第二季开始。
But whenever anybody says, I have a general question or I have a major problem.
但每当有人说我有一个一般性问题或我有一个重大问题时。
Everyone solutes and such general question, major problem.
大家解决这样的普遍问题、重大问题。
That's general questions.
这是一般性问题。
Yeah.
是的。
That is the.
那就是。
And this came from Alec.
这是亚历克说的。
Is this right?
这是对的吗？
This is my my my proudest my proudest moment in life was when I turned on the TV one Monday night.
这是我一生中最自豪的时刻，就是周一晚上我打开电视的那一刻。
And there was this stupid saluting thing that I annoyed everyone with in college, but they all picked it up.
我在大学里做过一个愚蠢的敬礼事，惹恼了每个人，但他们都接受了。
Craig Pate.
克雷格·佩特.
So, yeah, and I went to college, got a living on in college.
所以，是的，我上了大学，在大学里谋生。
He brainwashed me into doing this.
他给我洗脑让我这么做。
There is something sticky social contagion about the joke.
这个笑话具有某种粘性的社会感染力。
For some reason, even if you grown the first time you hear it, once you get it in your head, so it's major general and what, what else?
出于某种原因，即使你第一次听到它时就长大了，一旦你把它记在你的脑海里，所以它是少将，什么，还有什么？
Oh, private.
哦，私人的。
You can have a private conversation.
您可以进行私人对话。
private conversation, but you could take it, you could take it very far.
私人谈话，但你可以接受它，你可以进行得很远。
We'll get into that as the, as we don't want to give it all the way right here.
我们将深入探讨这一点，因为我们不想在这里就全部给出它。
But yes, there's a season two bit in on the show.
但是，是的，该剧还有第二季。
Alec, did I ask you permission to steal this bet?
亚历克，我有没有征得你的同意来偷这个赌注？
No, this is one of the many, many times I just stole things like a, like, a fucking dick.
不，这是我很多很多次偷东西的其中之一，就像一个该死的鸡巴一样。
No, but this, this was truly the prize.
不，但这，这确实是奖品。
And I will say that, was it a surprise, be honest?
我会说，说实话，这是一个惊喜吗？
Was it a surprise?
这是一个惊喜吗？
Absolutely.
绝对地。
It was absolutely was.
绝对是。
I guess I probably chose to surprise you, because I knew you would like it.
我想我可能选择给你惊喜，因为我知道你会喜欢的。
Absolutely wasn't I will say that I have a very good friend who told me that she used to do this with her friend You know 10 years ago 15 years ago from the show dude all the time I was like that's all coming in a circle, but speaking of bringing a circle and I'm just happy that you're finally gonna Get credit for this Alec.
绝对不是我会说我有一个非常好的朋友告诉我她曾经和她的朋友一起这样做你知道10年前15年前从节目中的家伙一直以来我都觉得这一切都在绕圈子，但说到绕圈子，我很高兴你终于会因为这个Alec而获得荣誉。
This is something This has been a long time coming all like this is why I'm doing this podcast my friends But to show how long a tale and amazing a story.
这已经是很长一段时间了，这就是我做这个播客的原因，我的朋友们，但为了展示一个故事有多长，一个故事有多精彩。
This is Josh you got an incredible letter I got, no, I got, I got an unbelievable note.
我是乔希，你收到了一封令人难以置信的信，我收到了，不，我收到了，我收到了一封令人难以置信的便条。
I won't say the names unless they authorize it because they didn't really write this for us to share the podcast, but it's so incredible.
除非他们授权，否则我不会说出这些名字，因为他们写这篇文章并不是为了我们分享播客，但这太不可思议了。
We have to share it.
我们必须分享它。
And fitting with me, stealing it from out like a little mess.
和我配合，像一个小混乱一样从外面偷走它。
Yeah, stealing is going to steal this kind of view.
是的，偷窃就会偷走这种观点。
This is from a couple who said that this is the husband writing me that his wife was 38 weeks pregnant with their daughter.
这是一对夫妇发来的，他们说这是丈夫写信给我，说他的妻子怀着他们的女儿已经怀孕 38 周了。
And the wife had had several days of early labor and pain before they finally admitted her to the hospital.
在他们最终将妻子送进医院之前，她已经经历了几天的早产和疼痛。
And then she had over 30 hours of labor in the hospital, which you guys have had wives who've given birth.
然后她在医院里待了30多个小时，你们这些人都已经生过孩子了。
That's a long time, right?
那是很长一段时间了，对吧？
That's a long run, man.
这是一个漫长的过程，伙计。
That's 30 hours of labor.
那是30个小时的劳动。
With her last pushes, the nurses said, push, you're having a major contraction and through all the pain and pushing my wife looks at me and salutes to major contraction.
在她最后一次用力时，护士说，用力，你正在经历剧烈宫缩，经历了所有的痛苦，用力，我的妻子看着我，向剧烈宫缩致敬。
It's just the best.
这只是最好的。
It's an unbelievable story.
这是一个令人难以置信的故事。
That's so, it's so good.
原来如此，真是太好了。
It's so good.
太好了。
So we thank you to the mighty marvelous couple out there, who today, how I met your mother inside joke at the moment of pushing a baby out.
所以，我们要感谢那里的一对伟大而奇妙的夫妇，今天，我在把婴儿推出来的那一刻，在笑话中遇见了你的母亲。
Inside joke is the baby came out.
里面的笑话是宝宝出来了。
I mean, what a, what a major contraction.
我的意思是，多么剧烈的收缩啊。
I mean, major respect to this amazing woman.
我的意思是，对这位了不起的女人表示极大的敬意。
And to whatever lucky gentleman got to marry her and have a child with her.
还有幸运的绅士娶了她并和她生了孩子。
That's that's unbelievable.
这就是令人难以置信的事情。
That's how you know.
你就是这样知道的。
That's how you know this marriage is going to last.
这就是你知道这段婚姻会持续下去的方式。
It's I have no doubt about that marriage.
我对那场婚姻毫不怀疑。
And Alec could did high school you that began this joke that presumably everyone hated you for sure.
亚历克可能会在高中时就开始讲这个笑话，想必每个人都讨厌你。
Did you could you ever have imagined this this would boomerang back around to us.
你有没有想过这会飞去来器回到我们身边。
And like that, this could possibly, is this a, is a blow your mind?
就这样，这可能，这，是不是让你大吃一惊？
No, that was the point.
不，这就是重点。
That was the point the whole time.
这就是一直以来的重点。
You played the long game.
你打了一场持久战。
Yeah.
是的。
And it was college.
那是大学。
I held off until I met you.
我一直拖延直到遇见你。
I didn't know them in high school.
我高中时不认识他们。
Yeah.
是的。
I thought it was cool to bust it out freshman here in college.
我觉得在大学一年级就能够解决这个问题很酷。
All right.
好的。
So, you know, we're, we've announced, we only announced the show a little time mending here.
所以，你知道，我们，我们已经宣布，我们只是宣布这个节目在这里修补了一下。
We announced the show in our lives, not that long ago, and have been flooded, not only with stories, but also literally a minute before we recorded our episode about the pilot.
不久前，我们在生活中宣布了这部剧，不仅充满了故事，而且在我们录制有关试播集的剧集前一分钟，我们都被淹没了。
I went on to Instagram and I said, hey, does anyone have any questions?
我去了 Instagram，我说，嘿，有人有任何问题吗？
And by the time the hour was done of recording, I had 350 of them, and I got to precisely almost zero because Josh and Craig just had so much to say about the pilot.
当一小时的录音结束时，我已经录制了 350 首，而我的录制几乎为零，因为乔什和克雷格对试播集有太多话要说。
So we thought we'd hold it off and just do a rapid fire, get some of the fan questions out here.
所以我们认为我们应该推迟并快速进行，在这里回答一些粉丝的问题。
Some of these you will have answered before.
其中一些您之前已经回答过。
And a lot of these are one question represents 10 questions that were of the same topic.
其中很多是一个问题代表同一主题的 10 个问题。
So let's just dive in.
那么让我们来深入了解一下吧。
So Alice 2388 asks, Josh, how much do you relate to Ted in real life?
所以爱丽丝2388问，乔什，你和现实生活中的泰德有多少关系？
I'll say that's a big question.
我会说这是一个大问题。
It's what we're going to be talking about through the whole series.
这就是我们将在整个系列中讨论的内容。
So I'm going to bend it a little bit if that's okay.
所以如果可以的话我会把它弯曲一点。
In our last That's the episode.
在我们的最后一集中，这就是这一集。
You said you sort of gave grace to your younger Josh Self.
你说你给了年轻的乔什·赛尔夫以恩典。
You had some advice for your younger Josh Self who was feeling certain things.
你给年轻的乔什·塞尔夫（Josh Self）一些建议，因为他对某些事情有感觉。
What would older Ted have to say to younger Ted in the pilot?
在试播集中，年长的泰德会对年轻的泰德说些什么？
He was a very intense guy.
他是一个非常热情的人。
What can you give him?
你能给他什么？
Well, I mean, it's more like, I mean, acting is so strange.
嗯，我的意思是，这更像是，我的意思是，表演是如此奇怪。
I always think about what my acting teacher at NYU said, Ron Van Lou.
我总是想起我在纽约大学的表演老师 Ron Van Lou 所说的话。
He said, a character is a 50% meeting of you and the character.
他说，一个角色就是你和这个角色50%的相遇。
So I lend 50% of the kind of DNA and the character, as Craig and Carter wrote, wrote the character is also that other 50%.
所以我借出了 50% 的 DNA 和角色，正如克雷格和卡特所写，所写的角色也是另外 50%。
So you're kind of like meeting this other thing to form this thing that looks like a dimensional real person.
所以你有点像遇到了另一个东西，形成了这个看起来像一个维度真人的东西。
So you know, I'm loathed to kind of act like 10.
所以你知道，我讨厌表现得像 10 号一样。
I don't know when people say like, oh, do it like 10.
我不知道什么时候人们会说，哦，像 10 那样做吧。
I'm like, I don't know.
我想，我不知道。
and I just do things in character.
我只是按照自己的性格做事。
I'm like, I don't know what you mean, like without the words from the script, like there is nothing, there's no character, but I am underneath the skin of them where I was for a long time.
我想，我不知道你的意思，就像没有剧本中的文字，就像什么都没有，没有角色，但我很长一段时间都在他们的皮肤下面。
I think, you know, if my younger self had told a woman that he was wildly attracted to that he loved her on the first date and kind of blew it.
我想，你知道，如果年轻时的我告诉一个女人，他在第一次约会时就被她深深吸引，他爱她，然后就搞砸了。
And I knew what I know now.
我知道我现在所知道的。
I would say, you know, Humiliation is part of life.
我想说，你知道，羞辱是生活的一部分。
Like it's almost like initiatory.
就像它几乎就像启动一样。
Like you get humiliated.
就像你被羞辱一样。
And I was listening to this guy Scott Galloway who's a really interesting thinker.
我正在听斯科特·加洛韦（Scott Galloway）的讲话，他是一位非常有趣的思想家。
And he's talking about men, the kind of crisis of manhood.
他谈论的是男人，男人气概的危机。
And he said, when men are just on their screens alone, they don't know how to take big swings out in the world.
他说，当男人只在屏幕上时，他们不知道如何在世界上做出巨大的改变。
They need to go out and learn to be humiliated.
他们需要走出去，学会被羞辱。
Now, I learned to be humiliated, honestly.
现在，我学会了诚实地接受羞辱。
Somewhat by women, but not as much.
部分是女性，但不多。
Here's what taught me humiliation, was being a young actor, going in, role after role, sometimes nailing it, not getting the job, sometimes getting the job, sometimes blowing it, you know, being unprepared, or just getting too nervous.
这就是让我感到羞辱的原因，作为一名年轻演员，一个接一个地扮演一个角色，有时能成功，但没有得到这份工作，有时得到这份工作，有时却搞砸了，你知道，没有准备好，或者只是变得太紧张。
Like, I really had to learn how to be humiliated and pick myself back up and keep going.
就像，我真的必须学会如何受到羞辱并振作起来并继续前进。
And I think it's one of the great qualities of Ted, which I hope I share is this ability to get knocked down.
我认为这是特德的伟大品质之一，我希望我也能分享这种被击倒的能力。
And he sometimes literally, like he got punched a lot in the show.
他有时确实，就像他在节目中被打了很多拳一样。
He sometimes literally gets punched down.
有时他确实会被打倒。
Punched down.
被一拳打倒了。
And he gets back up.
然后他又站了起来。
So I think it's more like, if someone's, if a younger person says, I got humiliated as an older mentor figure, I think you say, good.
所以我认为这更像是，如果有人，如果一个年轻人说，我作为一个年长的导师人物而受到羞辱，我想你会说，很好。
Yeah.
是的。
This is what you need.
这就是你所需要的。
You need to be humiliated.
你需要被羞辱。
You need to take swings.
你需要采取行动。
You need to put yourself out there and you need to get, somewhat you get need to get a thicker skin.
你需要把自己摆在那里，你需要，某种程度上，你需要变得更厚的脸皮。
You need to get immune to the kind of criticism and humiliation and just keep going.
你需要免受这种批评和羞辱，并继续前进。
So I would just tell them to pick himself up and it's all going to be all right.
所以我只会告诉他们振作起来，一切都会好起来的。
Ultimately, I think all anyone wants to hear is it's going to be okay.
最终，我认为所有人都想听到的是一切都会好起来的。
Yes.
是的。
Like, that's all anyone wants to hear ever.
就像，这就是任何人都想听到的。
Yeah.
是的。
Every night.
每个晚上。
It's the most evergreen piece of, like, pep talk advice you could give.
这是你能提供的最常青的建议，例如鼓舞士气的建议。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，是为了在纽约唱给你听。
Alec, you know what happened to me when I found a good therapist?
亚历克，你知道当我找到一位好的治疗师后我发生了什么吗？
What happened to you when you found a good therapist?
当你找到一位好的治疗师后，你发生了什么？
I married her.
我娶了她。
Oh!
哦！
My wife Jordana is a therapist, a wonderful therapist.
我的妻子乔丹娜是一位治疗师，一位出色的治疗师。
But today we're talking about Rula, which I believe Alec, you have used and can tell us a little more about.
但今天我们谈论的是 Rula，我相信 Alec 您已经使用过它，并且可以告诉我们更多相关信息。
I can, and I would like to announce first that I did not marry a single one of the therapists that I have used.
我可以，而且我想首先宣布，我没有与我所使用的治疗师中的任何一位结婚。
It's good to say that right up front.
最好提前说清楚。
Disclaimer.
免责声明。
Yes, no rule is, it's fantastic.
是的，没有规则，这太棒了。
It's a way of finding an online therapist, and I have used them for years.
这是寻找在线治疗师的一种方式，我已经使用它们很多年了。
It's basically built the way you would want a kind of website like this to be built.
它基本上是按照您想要的类似网站的方式构建的。
You go on, and you get to tell a little bit about what you're looking for, you get a list of therapists and they could be anywhere because this is entirely online, so you have a very large list.
你继续，你可以告诉一些你正在寻找的东西，你会得到一份治疗师名单，他们可能在任何地方，因为这完全是在线的，所以你有一个非常大的名单。
And they'll tell you about themselves, they have great bios of what brought them to this work, what interests them, what kind of work they've done in the past, what their techniques are, and you get to get a sense of who they are, which is completely different from we just walk into a therapist's office.
他们会告诉你他们自己，他们有很好的简历，告诉你是什么让他们从事这项工作，他们感兴趣什么，他们过去做过什么样的工作，他们的技术是什么，你可以了解他们是谁，这与我们走进治疗师的办公室完全不同。
You're just meeting this person for the first time.
你只是第一次见到这个人。
And what's really great about it is you can change and you could change because the fit isn't quite right or just actually just recently I changed because it had been a long time with one therapist and I just sort of had a sense that it was time to change and rule that makes it so easy you just go you have your list of therapists and you can just choose whoever you feel is the right fit for you.
它的真正伟大之处在于你可以改变，你可以改变，因为不适合你，或者实际上最近我才改变，因为与一位治疗师在一起已经很长时间了，我只是有一种感觉，是时候改变和规则了，这使得它变得如此容易，你只需去你的治疗师名单，你就可以选择任何你认为最适合你的人。
It almost sounds like Rula and I hope they're okay with me saying this.
这听起来几乎像鲁拉，我希望他们同意我这么说。
It's like a Somali A for therapists.
这就像治疗师的索马里 A 级。
It is.
这是。
It's exactly what it is.
就是这样。
You have to start what you're looking for and they say I have a lovely person in Denver Colorado for you.
你必须开始寻找你正在寻找的东西，他们说我在科罗拉多州丹佛有一个可爱的人适合你。
That's right.
这是正确的。
And they give you just a little bit.
他们只给你一点点。
You just take a little sip for at first.
一开始你只需喝一小口即可。
You just have your one appointment to see if it fits.
您只需预约一次，看看是否合适。
And if not, you send it back and you get that next bottle.
如果没有，您可以将其退回并获得下一瓶。
And I can attest as Alex's longtime friend.
作为亚历克斯的老朋友，我可以作证。
He used to be, he used to be a mess and now he's all, he's doing great.
他曾经是，他曾经一团糟，现在他一切都好，他做得很好。
You knew me in the pre-Rula days, those were dark days.
你在鲁拉之前的日子里认识我，那是黑暗的日子。
I didn't, I don't wish you pre-Rula on anyone.
我没有，我不希望你把鲁拉放在任何人身上。
But they've done great work with you.
但他们和你一起做了很棒的工作。
You're a shining example of what can happen.
你是可能发生的事情的光辉榜样。
RULA helps you find licensed therapists and psychiatrists who truly align with your background in goals rather than just assigning you the first open slot available.
RULA 帮助您找到真正符合您的目标背景的有执照的治疗师和精神科医生，而不是仅仅为您分配第一个可用的空缺职位。
Even better, RULA RULA RULA works with over 100 major insurance plans nationwide, bringing the average session copay to just $15.
更好的是，RULA RULA RULA 与全国 100 多个主要保险计划合作，使平均疗程自付额仅为 15 美元。
They support you from day one, tracking your milestones and helping you monitor your care along the way to ensure you're actually moving forward.
他们从第一天起就为您提供支持，跟踪您的里程碑并帮助您全程监控您的护理，以确保您真正取得进展。
As a young adult, finding the right path to your future can feel overwhelming.
作为一个年轻人，找到通往未来的正确道路可能会让人感到不知所措。
It starts with year-up, United's tuition-free job training program, Career Pathways.
它从一年级开始，联合航空的免学费职业培训计划“职业道路”。
If you're without a bachelor's degree, but have a high school diploma or GED, you can get skills first training to succeed in the industries you're passionate about, all while earning a weekly educational stipend to offset basic expenses.
如果您没有学士学位，但拥有高中文凭或 GED，您可以获得技能优先培训，以便在您热衷的行业中取得成功，同时每周赚取教育津贴来抵消基本费用。
In there, you'll have access to internships and hands-on experiences with Fortune 500 companies, and with Year Up United's job placement services and personalized coaching and mentorship, you can put your knowledge, skills, and most importantly, confidence into practice.
在那里，您将有机会获得财富 500 强公司的实习机会和实践经验，并通过 Year Up United 的就业安置服务以及个性化辅导和指导，您可以将您的知识、技能，最重要的是，信心付诸实践。
Apply to Year Up United today and take the first step toward achieving the career you want.
立即申请 Year Up United，迈出实现您想要的职业生涯的第一步。
Visit YearUp.org to learn more.
访问 YearUp.org 了解更多信息。
Snapple would like you to take a break from the sheds.
斯内普尔希望你能离开棚屋休息一下。
Those things you should be doing, should be finishing, should be thinking about.
那些你应该做、应该完成、应该思考的事情。
Well, right now, just, oh, crack open a Snapple, and just sit tight for a minute.
好吧，现在，只是，哦，打开一个 Snapple，然后坐一会儿。
Well, Craig and I share some Snapple real facts with you, not unlike Mr. Mosby's fun facts.
好吧，克雷格和我与您分享一些 Snapple 的真实事实，就像莫斯比先生的有趣事实一样。
Mr. Ted Mosby would have a lot of his fun facts.
特德·莫斯比先生会有很多有趣的事实。
He would love these, and some of these are even architecture related.
他会喜欢这些，其中一些甚至与建筑相关。
So give us our first fact.
那么请告诉我们第一个事实。
What do you guys?
你们做什么？
These all feel like things Ted or at least like a future, like dad Ted would say.
这些都感觉像是泰德的事情，或者至少像未来，就像泰德爸爸会说的那样。
All right, here is a Snapple Real Facts, 253.
好吧，这是 Snapple 的真实事实，253。
The first TV remote control introduced in 1950 was called Lazy Bones.
1950 年推出的第一个电视遥控器被称为“Lazy Bones”。
I didn't know that.
我不知道。
I mean, I mean, either.
我的意思是，我的意思是，要么。
Real fact, 1517 in New York, it is illegal to sell a haunted house without telling the buyer.
事实是，1517年在纽约，在不告诉买家的情况下出售鬼屋是违法的。
That's actually amazing.
这实际上是惊人的。
And that feels like a very, that feels like a very martial, actually.
实际上，这感觉就像是一种非常、非常武术的感觉。
These are weirdly resonant.
这些产生了奇怪的共鸣。
Okay, fact, that is amazing and I want to know more but we don't have time for it in the snaple chat.
好吧，事实上，这太棒了，我想了解更多，但我们没有时间在 snaple 聊天中进行了解。
Real facts, 1978, 1,978 I'm going to think has nothing to do with the year 1978.
真实的事实，1978 年，1,978 我认为与 1978 年无关。
More than 40 buildings in New York have their own zip codes.
纽约有 40 多座建筑物都有自己的邮政编码。
That is totally a Ted Mosby fund.
这完全是泰德·莫斯比基金。
That is.
那是。
He would actually know that.
他实际上会知道这一点。
He told every girl from that.
他告诉每个女孩。
Snaple real fact, 1,667.
斯内普真实事实，1,667。
Lovebirds are actual birds.
爱情鸟是真正的鸟类。
And we bring you back to love.
我们让你重拾爱。
It's all full circle.
这都是完整的循环。
It's all very him yummy.
这一切都非常美味。
All right.
好的。
That's your break.
那是你的休息时间。
Quick fun and just a little unexpected.
快速有趣，只是有点出乎意料。
Next time you hit pause and make a count with Snapple on your next break.
下次您按下暂停按钮并在下一次休息时使用 Snapple 进行计数。
The Dodger Munch asks a question.
道奇·蒙克提出了一个问题。
You must have gotten a lot back in the day, but let's cover it officially now.
当天您一定收获颇丰，但现在让我们正式介绍一下。
Why did you cast Bob Sagitt as the old Ted, which we could split that into two questions.
你为什么让鲍勃·萨吉特扮演老泰德，我们可以把它分成两个问题。
Why was there an old Ted?
为什么会有一个老泰德？
Yeah.
是的。
Period.
时期。
And why Bob Sagitt?
为什么是鲍勃·萨吉特？
This is Yeah, great.
这是啊，太棒了。
The great Bob Sagitt.
伟大的鲍勃·萨吉特。
By the way, let's yeah, the great Bob Sagitt.
顺便说一句，是的，伟大的鲍勃·萨吉特。
And we will we will get to the episode where we do a whole episode is about how much we love Bob Sagitt and how much we miss Bob Sagitt and how lucky we were to work with him.
我们将进入这一集，我们会用一整集来讲述我们有多么爱鲍勃·萨吉特，我们有多么想念鲍勃·萨吉特，以及我们有多么幸运能与他合作。
I'm so glad that we did it.
我很高兴我们做到了。
I will say that when we were first writing it, we thought the actor who played Ted would do the voiceover.
我要说的是，当我们第一次写它时，我们认为扮演泰德的演员会做画外音。
And in fact, I don't believe it was our idea to have an older person do do the role.
事实上，我不认为让年长的人来担任这个角色是我们的想法。
I think CBS, an older scheming network at the time, we were the youngest show on that network for all nine years that we were on that network, I believe, I think that's true.
我认为哥伦比亚广播公司，当时是一个较老的阴谋网络，我们是该网络九年来最年轻的节目，我相信，我认为这是真的。
I think the executives there said, because I think we had the idea we considered a different actor doing that voice, but I think we were leaning more towards Josh would do it, and I think I have to give credit to CBS and the studio for saying, there will be something here on CBS to having a trusted voice of an actor in his 50s who we've all grown up with.
我想那里的高管是这么说的，因为我认为我们有这样的想法，我们考虑让另一个演员来配音，但我认为我们更倾向于乔什来配音，我想我必须赞扬 CBS 和工作室的说法，CBS 会有一个值得信赖的 50 多岁演员的声音，我们都和他一起长大。
America's home funniest on videos, full house.
视频中最搞笑的美国之家，座无虚席。
He feels like your dad.
他感觉就像你的父亲。
He feels like this trusted part.
他感觉自己就是这个值得信赖的部分。
He's been in him.
他一直在他心里。
You're living room before and it will help the viewers that are watching CBS feel connected to the show in a way that maybe they wouldn't, but that was sort of the practical part.
你以前在客厅，这将帮助正在观看 CBS 的观众以一种他们可能不会的方式感受到与节目的联系，但这是一种实际的部分。
The creative part, and I think this was more important, was this idea that future you is kind of a different guy, right?
创意部分，我认为这更重要，是未来的你是一个不同的人，对吗？
The guy, the Ted in 2005 and the Ted in 2030, they're different people.
这个人，2005 年的 Ted 和 2030 年的 Ted，他们是不同的人。
Just like Josh Schneider, different people from 2005 and now, and having Bob do that role, he brought this kind of wisdom and warmth and to go back to Josh's question, ability to look back on having been humiliated with wit, humor, acceptance, grace, like he had that in his voice.
就像乔什·施奈德一样，从 2005 年到现在都是不同的人，让鲍勃扮演这个角色，他带来了这种智慧和温暖，回到乔什的问题，有能力以机智、幽默、接受、优雅的方式回顾被羞辱的经历，就像他的声音里有的那样。
He was a stand-up up comedian Bob Sagit.
他是一位单口喜剧演员鲍勃·萨吉特。
He went up and barmed in front of audiences.
他走上前，在观众面前大喊大叫。
He killed in front of audiences.
他在观众面前杀人。
You hear all his history and his voice.
你听到他所有的历史和他的声音。
He's a fantastic actor too.
他也是一位出色的演员。
He took the role really seriously.
他非常认真地对待这个角色。
He really loved Josh.
他真的很爱乔希。
He tried to get to know Josh and connect with Josh.
他试图了解乔什并与乔什建立联系。
So he was future Ted.
所以他就是未来的特德。
He would come hang out on the set.
他会来片场闲逛。
He didn't have to do that when he would come to voiceovers.
当他需要配音时，他不必这样做。
He'd come say hi because he wanted to feel what the show was and that sort of connection between these two Ted's but who were the same vibe over, different guys, the way we all are in 30, 25 years apart.
他会来打招呼，因为他想感受一下这个节目是什么，以及这两个 Ted 之间的联系，但他们有着相同的氛围，不同的人，就像我们都相隔 30、25 年一样。
I think it became such an asset to the show and I can't claim credit for it.
我认为它成为了这部剧的一笔财富，我不能将其归功于它。
In fact, we may have had to be, I think we got convinced of it through the process.
事实上，我们可能不得不这样做，我想我们在这个过程中已经确信了这一点。
And we were willing to have to be resistant.
我们愿意抵抗。
You know, I had a couple moments where I was like, man, I wish I was doing the voice, but I love, I ended up loving Bob so much that I was so happy that there was this introduction and that we got to be friends all these years.
你知道，有几次我想，伙计，我希望我能配音，但我爱，我最终非常爱鲍勃，所以我很高兴有这个介绍，而且这些年来我们成为了朋友。
But also it was fun to watch Bob.
但观看鲍勃的表演也很有趣。
He became a fan of the show because he would watch it in the sound booth and he loved the show.
他成为这个节目的粉丝，因为他会在音响室观看它并且他喜欢这个节目。
He did.
他做到了。
He loved it.
他喜欢它。
And yeah, I ultimately, I ultimately think it was the right move and I'm so glad that I knew him.
是的，我最终认为这是正确的举动，我很高兴认识他。
And also, you know, he and I had some real deep talks about being overly associated with the show because he had that with full house, you know.
而且，你知道，他和我就与这部剧的过度关联进行了一些真正的深入讨论，因为他在满座的情况下，你知道。
Yeah.
是的。
So he offered me some real wisdom and more than anything, just the wisdom to keep going.
所以他给了我一些真正的智慧，最重要的是，就是继续前进的智慧。
No, but I mean, think about Bob, Bob was a genius at complicating and diversifying his image past full house.
不，但我的意思是，想想鲍勃，鲍勃是一位天才，他擅长使自己的形象复杂化和多样化，超越满堂彩。
He really raised the idea of like, I'm going to show you some other moves.
他确实提出了这样的想法，我将向您展示一些其他动作。
I'm going to show you some other.
我要给你看一些其他的。
Which I was more comfortable on my own skin.
我对自己的皮肤感觉更舒服。
I wish I was more comfortable work in blue.
我希望穿蓝色工作更舒服。
That's not my, it's not my thing.
那不是我的，这不是我的事。
But it only worked with him because you knew he was a bench.
但这只对他有效，因为你知道他是板凳。
You knew he was all heart underneath it.
你知道他的内心是全心全意的。
It came across.
它遇到了。
There was a perpetual wink in it.
其中有一个永恒的眨眼。
Yeah.
是的。
Absolutely.
绝对地。
That's he was funny.
那就是他很有趣。
No, malice.
不，是恶意。
Yeah.
是的。
No, zero malice, all love.
不，零恶意，全是爱。
Yeah.
是的。
Dr. Marie 15, again, has a big question.
玛丽博士 15 再次提出了一个大问题。
But Josh, can you think of a time in that during the pilot or in those early days, weeks when you felt like, oh, this group is clicking this cast.
但是乔什，你能想象一下在试播期间或早期的几周里，你感觉，哦，这个团队正在点击这个演员阵容。
Well, you know, Neil and I had done a play together, like a really intense John Robin Bates play like months before.
嗯，你知道，尼尔和我一起演过一场戏，就像几个月前约翰·罗宾·贝茨 (John Robin Bates) 演的一场非常激烈的戏。
So I knew we worked well together.
所以我知道我们合作得很好。
I mean, I think it was pretty immediate.
我的意思是，我认为这是非常直接的。
I knew from the testing audition situation that Kobe and I had a real fizz together.
从试镜的情况来看，我知道科比和我在一起真的很兴奋。
And then when we got the whole gang together, I remember, I remember writers telling me that they all recognized that when the five of us were around that table was when the show felt so alive to them.
然后，当我们把整个团伙聚集在一起时，我记得，我记得作家们告诉我，他们都认识到，当我们五个人围坐在那张桌子旁时，这部剧对他们来说就显得如此生动。
So they were, in Craig, you can back me up on this, but like trying to write more for the five, you know, the five, the gang of five.
所以他们，在克雷格，你可以支持我这一点，但就像尝试为五个人写更多，你知道，五个人，五个人的帮派。
I think it was, I remember the champagne night, and maybe it was just because I was a little buzzed, but I definitely felt like we made something really great and I have a quiet good feeling about this because I had had everything happened to me in the world of making television pilots except getting a hit show.
我想是的，我记得那个香槟之夜，也许只是因为我有点兴奋，但我确实觉得我们做了一些非常伟大的事情，我对此有一种安静的良好感觉，因为在制作电视试播集的世界里，除了获得热门节目外，我经历过一切。
I got fired from my first one.
我从第一个工作中就被解雇了。
The second one got cancelled after six episodes.
第二部在六集后被取消。
The third one just didn't get picked up by the network, but I thought if anyone's going to go, I think it's going to be this one.
第三个没有被网络收录，但我想如果有人要去的话，我想那就是这个了。
I had that real strong feeling.
我有那种真正强烈的感觉。
We have a question here from our co-producer Doug's wife, Tally, so great friend of the show Tally's Tally does work blue Tally said fuck did they shoot all the future Ted scenes with the kids before they shot the rest of the show Greg Well, we didn't shoot it all before but we definitely We definitely got ahead of it and we definitely you know in season two is when we kind of grabbed all the future-looking stuff that pertained to the very ending.
我们的联合制片人道格的妻子塔利向我们提出了一个问题，塔利的好朋友塔利确实在蓝色工作。塔利说，他们在拍摄节目的其余部分之前，他们是不是和孩子们一起拍摄了所有未来的泰德场景？格雷格，好吧，我们之前没有全部拍摄过，但我们绝对领先了，我们绝对知道，在第二季中，我们抓住了所有与结局有关的未来的东西。
And we grabbed other stuff that we thought could slide in here or there.
我们还抓起了其他我们认为可以滑到这里或那里的东西。
Like, things just reactions, and we tried to, it was kind of funny.
就像，事情只是反应，我们尝试这样做，这有点有趣。
We just tried to imagine some reactions.
我们只是试图想象一些反应。
And we had some ideas that we thought would apply to future episode ideas, but mostly we shot that ending piece with them, right?
我们有一些想法，我们认为这些想法可以应用到未来的剧集创意中，但大多数时候我们都是用它们来拍摄结局的，对吧？
Because if the show was hit in one year, there were going to be too old.
因为如果这部剧一年内热播，那就太老了。
And that's what happened.
这就是发生的事情。
And so we just grabbed it.
所以我们就抓住了它。
It was it looking back of his real like Babe Ruth's call your shot ball or move to be like clear the set We need these two we child actors and they're gonna sign non-disclosure forms, which they did Wow one camera man.
回顾他的真实情况，就像贝比·鲁斯（Babe Ruth）叫你的投球或移动一样清理布景，我们需要这两个我们的儿童演员，他们要签署保密表格，他们做到了，哇，一个摄影师。
We had one sound person who also signed those forms and everybody else in the set sets Usually a pretty crowded place We cleared them out.
我们有一个健全的人也签署了这些表格，而片场中的其他人通常是一个非常拥挤的地方，我们把他们清理干净了。
I think we did it at the beginning of a day or an end of a day And we just nobody else me and Carter Pam Susie those two actors David and Lindsey the kids And that was it, and we just thought we have to do this, and if we, you know, however many years pass, we'll always have shot this.
我想我们是在一天的开始或一天结束的时候拍的 我们只是我和卡特·帕姆·苏西 这两个演员 大卫和林赛 孩子们 就是这样，我们只是认为我们必须这样做，如果我们，你知道，无论过去多少年，我们总是会拍这个。
We'll never regret having grabbed it.
我们永远不会后悔抓住它。
There's no way to grab it eight, nine years from now, so we're going to get it now.
从现在起八、九年之后就没有办法得到它，所以我们现在就得到它。
So we just, yeah, it was an example of using the format of the show to really think forward and think about the future of the show is about the future.
所以我们只是，是的，这是一个利用节目形式来真正思考未来的例子，并思考节目的未来是关于未来的。
And so I think our brains were just in that mode.
所以我认为我们的大脑就处于这种模式。
And so we said, let's do it and let's grab it.
所以我们说，让我们去做吧，让我们抓住它。
We had the idea, let's grab it.
我们有了这个想法，让我们抓住它。
We have a lot of questions about the order in which scenes were shot and I feel like at another time what might be good to go through just for for for fans you don't really know the way TV is put together is kind of let's talk about how the show is happens from Monday through Friday so I feel like let's put a pin in that so people see the that Josh do you remember after champagne moment after the show is edited do you remember just watching the pilot for the first time and what your reaction was Craig same question Do you afterwards?
我们对场景的拍摄顺序有很多疑问，我觉得在另一个时候，对于那些不太了解电视制作方式的粉丝来说，可能有什么好处，让我们谈谈这部剧从周一到周五是如何发生的，所以我觉得让我们把它钉在上面，这样人们就可以看到乔希，你记得在节目编辑后喝完香槟的那一刻，你还记得第一次看试播集吗？你的反应是什么，克雷格也有同样的问题吗？之后？
Yeah, I can't remember the first time I saw it.
是啊，我已经不记得第一次看到它是什么时候了。
I can't remember if I got a link.
我不记得是否有链接。
I think that Pam maybe invited us as a cast to watch it.
我想帕姆可能邀请我们作为演员观看。
Do you remember Craig?
你还记得克雷格吗？
Do you remember showing it?
你还记得展示过它吗？
I was going to say, I don't know if you got a link.
我想说的是，不知道你有没有链接。
You might have got a fucking VHS tape.
你可能有一盘他妈的VHS录像带。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
No, I didn't get a CD.
不，我没有拿到 CD。
I don't know.
我不知道。
I don't remember, but I remember DVD.
我不记得了，但我记得DVD。
Yeah.
是的。
And then I ended up watching it a bunch of times with an audience because we, you know, watched it with the audience to get the laughter.
然后我和观众一起看了很多遍，因为我们，你知道，和观众一起看它是为了获得笑声。
I think I saw it a bunch.
我想我看到了一堆。
I've seen the pilot probably more than any other episode.
我看过试播集的次数可能比其他任何一集都多。
Yeah, and Greg, you obviously saw it all through the editing process.
是的，格雷格，你显然在整个编辑过程中看到了这一切。
It's different for me because we edited the hell out of it.
这对我来说是不同的，因为我们对其进行了彻底的编辑。
It wasn't like eight minutes up.
还不到八分钟。
It was supposed to be 22 minutes.
本来应该是22分钟。
It was 31 or whatever it was.
那是 31 或其他什么。
And we spent weeks whittling it, editing it down.
我们花了几周的时间来削减、编辑它。
And the weirdest part was watching a focus group test audience watch it with their dials of like like and don't like.
最奇怪的部分是看着焦点小组测试观众用喜欢和不喜欢的表盘观看它。
And these dials that are all averaged together of this room full of people watching it.
这些刻度盘都是在这个满是观看它的人的房间里平均在一起的。
in real time, you see the lines going up and down of male approval or disapproval and female approval or disapproval.
实时地，你会看到男性认可或不认可以及女性认可或不认可的线条上下起伏。
I think one's blue and one's pink in a stereotypical fashion.
我认为一个是蓝色的，一个是粉红色的，这是一种典型的时尚。
And it's like, oh, women like that moment, men did not.
就像，哦，女人喜欢那一刻，男人不喜欢。
And it's just so weird.
这太奇怪了。
So I watched the pilot every way you could possibly watch the pilot.
所以我以一切可能的方式观看了试播集。
And it was super weird, some of them.
其中一些非常奇怪。
But then when we had it locked, or almost locked and showed it to a live audience and recorded their laughs and their responses, which was what aired in the show.
但当我们把它锁定或几乎锁定并向现场观众展示并记录他们的笑声和反应时，这就是节目中播出的内容。
For that one, that was fantastic because people, you knew it worked.
对于那个人来说，这太棒了，因为人们知道它有效。
You knew it worked.
你知道它有效。
I knew it worked before that because everybody that came into the edit room and watched it every moment that had to work worked.
在那之前我就知道它是有效的，因为每个进入编辑室并在需要工作的时刻观看它的人都有效。
So I felt confident but the best the best moment was finally getting the show into an audience full of humans and then we're not assessing it in any way they were watching it and reacting naturally.
所以我感到很有信心，但最好的最好的时刻是最终让节目进入全人类的观众，然后我们不会以任何方式评估它，他们正在观看它并做出自然的反应。
How much Craig at the time and this might I have changed over the course as the show became more successful and you more confident in this new crazy job that you had, how much of these other voices, whether it's audience reaction or test audience reaction or executives, how much is actually influencing your writing of the show?
随着节目变得更加成功，你对自己的这项新的疯狂工作更有信心，当时的克雷格和我可能会改变多少，这些其他声音有多少，无论是观众反应还是测试观众反应或高管，实际上有多少影响了你对节目的写作？
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, I think a good note is a good note.
我的意思是，我认为好笔记就是好笔记。
I think we had some very smart executives from both the studio and the network and who were really believed in the show and supported it.
我认为我们有一些来自工作室和网络的非常聪明的高管，他们真正相信并支持这部剧。
And it took some time, sometimes for people, for them to get on board, but sort of have serialized the show was and sort of emotional and stuff like that.
人们花了一些时间才加入进来，但有点连载了这部剧，有点情绪化之类的。
But for the most part, they just want to know what was best for the show.
但大多数情况下，他们只是想知道什么对节目最有利。
And it was actually very helpful because we didn't shoot it in front of a live studio audience.
这实际上非常有帮助，因为我们没有在现场演播室观众面前拍摄。
So those responses meant something.
所以这些回应是有意义的。
If we got notes about confusion or boredom or something was slow, and just it came from that human like, an executive is saying to me, I felt confused here.
如果我们收到关于困惑、无聊或缓慢的事情的记录，并且只是来自那个人，一位高管对我说，我在这里感到困惑。
Or this felt really rushed to me.
或者这对我来说真的很匆忙。
That's good.
那挺好的。
That's really useful.
这真的很有用。
That's a human reaction.
这是人类的反应。
They felt that in their gut and they told us the other thing was really useful and I think Carter pointed this out in his episode.
他们本能地感觉到这一点，他们告诉我们另一件事非常有用，我认为卡特在他的剧集中指出了这一点。
The crew reacted when we'd perform these scenes, the actors would perform these scenes and the crew wouldn't have read every line of every script or like the new rewrite or whatever that came out the night before we shot and they'd react honestly to stuff.
当我们表演这些场景时，工作人员会做出反应，演员会表演这些场景，工作人员不会阅读每个剧本的每一行，或者像新的重写或我们拍摄前一天晚上出现的任何内容，他们会对这些东西做出诚实的反应。
They'd really laugh.
他们真的会笑。
That's the only one.
这是唯一的一个。
And go cricket silence.
并保持板球沉默。
And it was only that first time.
这只是第一次。
So you had to kind of aggregate responses.
所以你必须汇总回应。
You're getting some responses from different places, and you sort of aggregate them.
您从不同的地方收到一些回复，然后将它们汇总起来。
And especially if you see link ups, and you're like, oh, that didn't work in three different settings now.
尤其是当您看到链接时，您会想，哦，现在这在三种不同的设置中不起作用。
It didn't work at the table read, the crew didn't laugh, et cetera, et cetera.
它在餐桌上不起作用，工作人员没有笑，等等。
And you sort of had to take the hit and go, okay, let's take this as a sign, we may need to change it.
你不得不接受打击然后走，好吧，让我们把这当作一个标志，我们可能需要改变它。
But some stuff you got to believe in, even if it doesn't play on its feet in front of the crew, you say, this is a quiet moment we can, well, this will work in the other room.
但有些东西你必须相信，即使它在工作人员面前表现不佳，你也会说，这是一个安静的时刻，我们可以，好吧，这将在另一个房间发挥作用。
There's a different kind of moment.
有一个不同的时刻。
So it's a case by case.
所以这是具体情况而定。
And Josh, I assume you're basically, at this point, insulated from the larger, louder voices about the show should be more of this, the stuff that Craig and Carter are hearing.
乔什，我想你现在基本上已经与有关该节目的更大、更响亮的声音隔绝了，应该更多的是克雷格和卡特听到的东西。
For you and your process early on, can you talk a little bit about what is affecting you?
对于您和您的早期流程，您能谈谈影响您的因素吗？
Because unlike a play where you're working on this one character and you know it's gotta be contained within this two hours, do have it in somewhere in your head of like the choices that I'm making for this character could live for years, could live as it turns out for a decade.
因为与戏剧不同的是，你正在处理这个角色，并且你知道它必须包含在这两个小时内，所以一定要把它放在你头脑中的某个地方，就像我为这个角色所做的选择可能会持续数年，可能会持续十年。
What's happening as you're developing that early on?
当你这么早就开始发育时，发生了什么？
Obviously, with the scripts that you're being handed.
显然，通过您收到的脚本。
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, I think any sort of notes from the Studio Network, I was super insulated from that on the pilot at the very least.
我的意思是，我认为来自 Studio Network 的任何类型的注释，我至少在试播集上与这些注释完全隔离。
Then you end up getting to know the Studio in Network Executives, and they're there every week, and they're, you know, you become really friendly with them.
然后你最终会了解网络主管的工作室，他们每周都会在那里，你知道，你会与他们变得非常友好。
It's not they were they never felt like the enemy was walking on to stage, you know?
他们并不是从来没有感觉到敌人走上舞台，你知道吗？
But I would I was very interested in process and in writing So I remember I was probably alone Among the cast members and Craig can tell me if I'm wrong I was probably the most curious about process I was probably the one who asked the most about what was coming up and what you guys were working on and what you were struggling with and like I was just I had an endless appetite for those kinds of questions Some of it was like a little bit like what's coming down the pike like I wanted to you know you become a fan of the show, too I was like I want to know what happens to this guy But You know I still was a relative newcomer to the world of filmed entertainment I had done it so much theater since I was 15 and theater the mercy of theater and somewhat of the sadness of theater is It's a femoral it goes away you do it and then you have to keep doing it it's much more like a restaurant where you have to keep making the food every night, you know?
但我希望我对过程和写作非常感兴趣所以我记得我可能是唯一一个在演员阵容中，克雷格可以告诉我我是否错了，我可能是对过程最好奇的人我可能是问得最多的人，关于即将发生的事情，你们正在做什么，你们正在努力解决什么问题，就像我对这些问题有着无尽的胃口一样，有些就像是有点像即将发生的事情，就像我想让你知道你也成为了这个节目的粉丝一样我就像我想知道这个家伙发生了什么事，但你知道，我对电影娱乐世界来说仍然是一个相对较新的人，从我15岁起，我就已经在戏剧界做过很多次了，戏剧的怜悯和戏剧的一些悲伤是，它是一种股骨，它会消失，你这样做，然后你必须继续这样做，这更像是一家餐馆，你必须每天晚上继续做饭，你知道吗？
Yeah, and you don't have to be haunted by the bad night's performance, or that you're even get to celebrate that much the good night's performance.
是的，你不必被糟糕的夜晚表现所困扰，或者你甚至不必庆祝美好的夜晚表现。
It's just, it, it, Evan Necesses is that the word.
只是，它，它，Evan Necesses 就是这个词。
It just goes away.
它就消失了。
Right.
正确的。
And with filmed entertainment, uh, I, I found it took me years to, um, become less self-conscious and to not think about the kind of like museum quality of it, that it would last forever and I always, always, always wanted another take if one was available because I just wanted another whack at the thing.
对于电影娱乐节目，呃，我，我发现我花了很多年的时间才变得不那么不自在，不再去思考它的那种像博物馆一样的品质，它会永远持续下去，如果有的话，我总是、总是、总是想要再拍一次，因为我只是想再重击一遍。
But it wasn't until I directed my own movies and I was in both the movies I directed where I had to edit myself and I learned so much, I learned, it was weird, something happened to me where I was like, I know what I look like now.
但直到我导演了自己的电影，而且我在自己导演的两部电影中都必须自己剪辑，我学到了很多东西，我知道，这很奇怪，我身上发生了一些事情，我知道我现在是什么样子。
You know when you're a kid and you hear your voice on tape for the first time and you're like horrified, you're like, that can't be what I sound like, right?
你知道，当你还是个孩子的时候，第一次在磁带上听到自己的声音，你会感到害怕，你会想，这不可能是我听起来的样子，对吧？
You go through that a little bit when you see yourself on camera, like Craig and Carter as the fireman or the EMT guys.
当你在镜头前看到自己时，你会稍微经历一下这一点，就像克雷格和卡特扮演的消防员或急救人员一样。
But you still haunts me.
但你仍然困扰着我。
There was this feeling once I edited myself.
我自己编辑的时候就有这种感觉。
I was like, I didn't think I looked particularly good or bad.
我当时想，我不认为我看起来特别好或坏。
I just knew what I looked like and I had a kind of ruthless acceptance of it.
我只知道我的样子，并且我无情地接受它。
And since I've done that, I have a much easier time watching myself on screen.
自从我这样做了，我就可以更轻松地在屏幕上观看自己。
It still pops up where you're like, I don't know where I wish they would have chosen a different take or something, but it's hard.
它仍然会出现在你喜欢的地方，我不知道我希望他们在哪里选择不同的方式或其他什么，但这很难。
It's hard.
这很难。
I think that people don't understand how much self-consciousness is induced by acting on screen.
我认为人们不明白银幕上的表演会引发多少自我意识。
And when I see people, you know, like Lizzy Olson, who was in my first, in my second movie, Liberal Arts, like, she was just, She's just two the men are born.
当我看到人们时，你知道，就像莉兹·奥尔森（Lizzy Olson），她在我的第一部电影和第二部电影《人文艺术》中，就像，她只是，她只是两个男人出生的人。
I think Kobe was like this too, like they're just comfortable being photographed and, you know, fussed over in a way that I coming from the theater and I don't know, just my general kind of level of self-consciousness back in those days.
我认为科比也是这样，就像他们很舒服地被拍照，而且，你知道，以一种我从剧院出来的方式大惊小怪，我不知道，只是我当时的一般自我意识水平。
I had a harder time relaxing.
我很难放松。
I feel like I know how to act in front of the camera in a totally different way than I did 20 years ago.
我觉得我知道如何在镜头前表现得与 20 年前完全不同。
All right, we have two questions representing many who asked the same.
好吧，我们有两个问题代表了许多提出同样问题的人。
Let's do it.
我们开始做吧。
PJ Chandra 612 says, what was the inspiration behind a blue French horn?
PJ Chandra 612 说，蓝色圆号背后的灵感是什么？
I mean, I think that came from, I remember us wanting to, by the way, it's right over Josh's shoulder right there.
我的意思是，我认为这是来自，我记得我们想要，顺便说一句，它就在乔什的肩膀上。
I don't know if he's the next question on camera here and our little, if anyone's YouTubeing us, it's fantastic.
我不知道他是否是下一个在镜头前提问的人，如果有人在 YouTube 上播放我们的视频，那就太棒了。
It makes me very happy.
这让我非常高兴。
Josh, there's a lovely fire.
乔什，有一堆可爱的火。
I can't tell if you have the fire today.
我不知道今天是否着火了。
You do.
你做。
It's always a lovely fire.
这总是一团可爱的火。
So winter and there's the blue punch on it's very appealing.
所以冬天，上面有蓝色的打孔器非常吸引人。
It came from the idea of the Carter and I were we knew we wanted Ted to have to to bring something in this sort of very elemental storytelling way like you've got to he's got to bring the heroine a gift To gain entry Into into her layer.
它来自卡特和我的想法，我们知道我们希望泰德必须以这种非常基本的讲故事方式带来一些东西，就像他必须给女主角带来一份礼物才能进入她的层一样。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Like there was just this sort of almost like Greek mythological Like he must he must get a gift and that will that will gain him access into her a good world a boon Yeah, it really was it feels it feels very like Joseph Campbell, mythology, kind of like just like, let's boil it down to the hero needs to do this to sort of earn his way.
就像有一种几乎像希腊神话一样，他必须得到一份礼物，这将使他进入她的美好世界，这是一种恩赐，是的，感觉非常像约瑟夫·坎贝尔，神话，有点像，让我们把它归结为英雄需要这样做才能赢得自己的方式。
And then it was like, let's think of something memorable that could hang on a wall.
然后就像，让我们想一些可以挂在墙上的难忘的东西。
And I was like, we got to that.
我当时想，我们做到了。
You also get the feeling Ted was not into thieving that much.
你还会感觉到泰德不太喜欢偷窃。
Like he doesn't seem like he was a guy who stole a lot of things off a wall from restaurants.
他看起来不像是一个从餐馆的墙上偷了很多东西的人。
I have these moments a lot, but I'm like, we should have talked about that.
我有很多这样的时刻，但我想，我们应该讨论一下。
Like Ted, do you ever stolen anything before?
像特德一样，您以前偷过东西吗？
That could have been a whole episode.
这可能是一整集。
times the whole gang stole something.
有一次，整个团伙都偷了东西。
Damn it.
该死的。
But yeah, that that would have been a new thing for Ted, I believe in my heart.
但是，是的，这对特德来说是一件新鲜事，我内心相信。
That was that was his first theft, I think, and he had the idea that he had to run in and do and sort of like going back to just earlier coming about sort of humiliating yourself in order to sort of move forward in the game.
我认为那是他的第一次盗窃，他有一个想法，他必须跑进去做，有点像回到早些时候羞辱自己，以便在游戏中前进。
He had to run and jump onto a couple's dinner table, put his knee in like the entrees and grab this thing off the wall.
他必须跑跳到一对情侣的餐桌上，像主菜一样把膝盖伸进去，然后把这个东西从墙上抓下来。
Or this couple is sort of a humiliating and same thing to do, But it got him to the next level of the, the rom-com video game to go meet the boss.
或者说，这对夫妇有点丢脸，而且做同样的事情，但这让他进入了浪漫喜剧视频游戏的下一个阶段，去见老板。
I do remember shooting that and enjoying it.
我确实记得拍摄并享受它。
It was so quick.
太快了。
It was fun.
很有趣。
And it was almost like doing your own stunt.
这几乎就像是你自己做特技一样。
Like it was a little like, there was some athleticism to it.
有点像，有一些运动天赋。
You know, it was really fun.
你知道，这真的很有趣。
I was surprised re-watching it.
我重新观看时感到很惊讶。
I was like, oh, he really had to climb up on a table and get that thing.
我当时想，哦，他真的必须爬上桌子才能拿到那个东西。
It was really me climbing up on that table.
真的是我爬上那张桌子。
It was actually all his own stunts there.
其实这全是他自己的绝技。
Well, Ivana, Ivana Vasku, sorry, Ivana, does ask, did any of you keep the blue French horn?
好吧，伊万娜，伊万娜·瓦斯库，抱歉，伊万娜，我问，你们有人保留蓝色圆号吗？
And remember, this is audio, this is an audio format, Josh, so please talk about through this.
请记住，这是音频，这是音频格式，乔什，所以请通过这个来讨论。
Yeah, it's just over my my right shoulder.
是的，它就在我的右肩上。
We were just kind of asked by the props department and by Carter and Craig, like, if you could take one thing, and I asked for the blue French horn.
道具部门、卡特和克雷格问我们是否可以拿一件东西，我要了蓝色圆号。
And I don't, I didn't, I mean, it was so associated with Ted.
我不，我不，我的意思是，它与特德有如此密切的联系。
I don't think there There's a lot of competition for, you know, I don't think Carlin will bartender is like, give me that.
我不认为有很多竞争，你知道，我不认为卡林调酒师会喜欢，给我那个。
Yeah.
是的。
Um, so, uh, yeah, so I asked for the horn and I, it's traveled with me.
嗯，所以，呃，是的，所以我要了号角，它跟我一起旅行。
I'm now in, uh, I now live in Albuquerque, New Mexico, um, downtown Albuquerque.
我现在在，呃，我现在住在新墨西哥州阿尔伯克基，嗯，阿尔伯克基市中心。
But it's been with me for a number of years, yeah.
但它已经伴随我很多年了，是的。
It makes me so happy every time we do this podcast to see it over Josh's right shoulder.
每次我们做这个播客，从乔什的右肩上看到它时，我都感到非常高兴。
It makes me, every time I sort of forget that it's there and then it's there and it's like, it's delightful.
它让我，每次我有点忘记它的存在，然后它就在那里，它就像，它是令人愉快的。
by the way, you just mentioned the bartender.
顺便说一句，你刚才提到了调酒师。
Do you guys know Joe, right?
你们认识乔吗？
Do you guys know his story of how he wound up on nine seasons of the show?
你们知道他如何结束九季节目的故事吗？
Do you know how it started?
你知道它是怎么开始的吗？
Well, I mean, I do because I was there.
嗯，我的意思是，我这么做是因为我在那里。
Do you mean he weren't there?
你的意思是他不在场？
Can you tell the story?
你能讲一下这个故事吗？
He was, he was going to be a cop that appeared, that appeared in a whole sequence that got acts on the show.
他是，他将成为一名警察，出现在整个节目中并在节目中表演。
I think we cut it.
我认为我们削减了它。
I'm not sure we even, I think we didn't even, did we shoot it, God.
我不确定我们甚至，我想我们甚至没有，我们是否拍摄过它，上帝。
We didn't shoot it.
我们没有拍摄它。
He showed up.
他出现了。
He's right.
他是对的。
I think production forgot to call him and tell him it was cut.
我想制作组忘记给他打电话并告诉他影片被剪掉了。
Yes.
是的。
That was it.
就是这样。
And he got in his costume.
他穿上了戏服。
Someone put a costume on him of a cop.
有人给他穿上了警察的服装。
He showed up and that's an, that's a question that will haunt me.
他出现了，这是一个困扰我的问题。
Did word drove.
言语驱动了吗？
No, it was cut, but it was like, let's put him in the cop out there.
不，它被剪掉了，但就像是，让我们把他放在警察那里。
We don't want to be the one to tell him.
我们不想成为告诉他的人。
That's now that I don't know that question.
现在我不知道这个问题了。
So when he shows up to set in a cop outfit and you say, sorry, this has been cut.
所以当他穿着警察装出现在片场时，你会说，对不起，这已经被剪掉了。
No, you can get behind the bar and be the bartender.
不，你可以到吧台后面当调酒师。
That's it.
就是这样。
Yeah.
是的。
That was it.
就是这样。
We felt it because we were still casting the bartender role and we liked him and we had to cast him and then cut this thing at the last minute about a cop.
我们之所以有这种感觉，是因为我们还在选调酒师的角色，而且我们喜欢他，所以我们不得不选他，然后在最后一刻剪掉这个关于警察的故事。
It was like a cop that was going to come on the other one.
就像一个警察要来对付另一个人一样。
They were all sitting out on the the taxi cab outside of Robin's apartment.
他们都坐在罗宾公寓外的出租车上。
There was a whole little bit with a cop and I don't even ask me if I've ever been in what it is because I'm kind of blanking on what it really was.
有一个警察的一点点，我什至没有问我是否曾经经历过它是什么，因为我对它到底是什么感到茫然。
We cut it and we felt so bad that the message never got to him somehow and that we said, you were great.
我们剪掉了它，我们感到非常难过，以至于这个信息不知何故从未传达给他，我们说，你很棒。
Let's make you Carl the bartender and then he appeared for nine years on the show unbelievable.
让我们让你扮演调酒师卡尔，然后他在节目中出现了九年，令人难以置信。
You never know to shout out to Joe, though.
不过，你永远不知道该向乔大声喊叫。
Joe was awesome.
乔太棒了。
Shout out to Joe Joe was great.
向乔乔大喊大叫太棒了。
He was always so much fun to have on set.
他在片场总是那么有趣。
He was so chill.
他好冷淡。
Yeah.
是的。
Also, I forgot in the pilot.
另外，我忘了在飞行员中。
He has that.
他有那个。
You have that moment.
你有那个时刻。
He glairs at me because he has mean as his.
他对我怒目而视，因为他也很卑鄙。
I forgot that moment too.
我也忘记了那一刻。
I forgot that.
我忘记了。
I forgot that she was Carl's girlfriend for a second.
我有一瞬间忘记了她是卡尔的女朋友。
I was like one of those little bit.
我就像其中的一员。
I mostly had that verbatim that pilot in my brain, but it's like, right.
我脑子里大部分都是逐字逐句地记着，但它就像是，对的。
Carl's he's dating Carl and He has a good, intimidating look at Ted.
卡尔正在和卡尔约会，他对特德的态度很好，令人生畏。
That's great.
那太棒了。
Carl.
卡尔.
It's the most murdering there.
这是那里最凶残的。
Carl ever got.
卡尔曾经得到过。
Yeah.
是的。
Craig, he was good.
克雷格，他很好。
He had a presence.
他有存在感。
He was great.
他很棒。
Go, Joe.
走吧，乔。
And sorry about the cop thing, Joe, but I guess it worked out way, way better.
乔，对警察的事情感到抱歉，但我想事情已经解决了，好多了。
We have so many questions and so little time.
我们的问题太多，时间却太少。
Craig, you and I have bonded over for all of our many, many decades together.
克雷格，你和我在一起数十年以来一直保持着深厚的感情。
But it is Douglas asked what books, TV shows, or stories in general help guide how to tell the first episode.
但道格拉斯问的是，哪些书籍、电视节目或一般故事可以帮助指导如何讲述第一集。
I guess bigger question, what are your biggest writing, comedy, influences?
我想更大的问题是，你最大的写作、喜剧、影响是什么？
I mean, Carter would have a certain set of answers that would be very important to this too.
我的意思是，卡特会有一套对此也非常重要的答案。
I won't attempt to speak for him, but so many of our answers were overlaps.
我不会试图代表他说话，但我们的许多答案都是重叠的。
This is one, cheers.
这是一个，干杯。
I think we wanted to do a show that had a bar in it and you wanted to hang out with these people at the bar and we wanted the bar to be super inviting and warm and amazing and we just took that from cheers.
我想我们想做一个有酒吧的节目，你想在酒吧里和这些人一起出去玩，我们希望酒吧非常有吸引力、温暖和令人惊叹，我们只是从欢呼声中得到了这一点。
But we also love Quentin Tarantino and we love slicing and dicing narratives and storytelling and finding these nonlinear crazy ways to tell stories.
但我们也喜欢昆汀·塔伦蒂诺，我们喜欢对叙事和讲故事进行切片和切块，并找到这些非线性的疯狂方式来讲述故事。
So I'd say Quentin Tarantino plus cheers equals how much your mother with someone Harry Metzali thrown in.
所以我想说昆汀·塔伦蒂诺加上欢呼声等于你母亲和哈利·梅扎利投入的数量。
I think you guys told me on the pilot that you had pitched Ted as Lloyd Dobler from say anything meets George Bailey from its a wonderful life.
我想你们在试播集里告诉我，你们之所以选择泰德饰演劳埃德·多布勒，是因为你们说的任何事情都能满足乔治·贝利的美好生活。
Was it were those the two comps that you gave?
是你给的那两个比较吗？
Absolutely, absolutely.
绝对，绝对。
Big time and with a special emphasis on George Bailey, I think, because think about the planning aspect.
我想，这很重要，而且特别强调乔治·贝利，因为考虑到规划方面。
I'm gonna plan my feature.
我要规划我的特色。
This is what the feature is gonna be.
这就是该功能的样子。
I've got it all mapped out.
我已经把一切都安排好了。
I mean, in some ways, it's an actionable ripoff.
我的意思是，从某些方面来说，这是一种可采取行动的抄袭行为。
We really, we really took a lot from it's of George Bailey, main character of its wonderful life for you kids playing along in the home game.
我们真的，我们真的从乔治贝利那里学到了很多东西，他是你们孩子们在主场比赛中度过的美好生活的主角。
He's this big dreamer who thinks he's gonna plan everything out and life proves otherwise and life also proves that there's a richness to be found when it doesn't all go according to plan.
他是一个伟大的梦想家，他认为自己会计划好一切，但生活证明并非如此，生活也证明，当一切不按计划进行时，可以发现丰富的东西。
I'd say that was a big spiritual forebearer of Ted, but Lloyd Dobler, big time.
我想说这是泰德的一位伟大的精神先驱，但劳埃德·多布勒是伟大的。
I mean, so much so with Lloyd Dobler, that when you walked in the door and had a little Qzaki inequality to you, Josh, it's red first, so you're not to say like, you seemed like John Geary, your own man, but it definitely helped.
我的意思是，劳埃德·多布勒（Lloyd Dobler）是如此，当你走进门并对你有一点Qzaki不平等时，乔什（Josh），它首先是红色的，所以你不能说，你看起来像约翰·吉尔里（John Geary），你自己的人，但这确实有帮助。
There was kind of like a wit and an intelligence in your eyes that felt like a young John Qzaki.
你的眼睛里有一种机智和智慧，感觉就像年轻的约翰·卡扎基(John Qzaki)。
Oh no.
哦不。
At that time, my life is someone called Netsu Sakki, and I would take it as a big compliment.
那时，我的生命中有一个叫热佐木的人，我会把它当作一个很大的赞美。
You didn't miss it.
你没有错过。
Okay.
好的。
Yeah.
是的。
My last question on paper here is from Chris.ram asks, will you be filming this podcast?
我在纸上的最后一个问题是 Chris.ram 提出的，你会拍摄这个播客吗？
So here we are.
所以我们到了。
They're very excited.
他们非常兴奋。
If you are listening to this right now, just know that this is also on YouTube.
如果您现在正在听这个节目，请知道 YouTube 上也有这个节目。
You can check it out.
你可以检查一下。
There's so many questions about this pilot.
关于这个飞行员有很多问题。
There's 300 more here on Instagram and everywhere.
Instagram 上和其他地方还有 300 多个。
Is there anything left?
还有东西吗？
What else should we talk about about the pilot?
关于飞行员我们还应该谈论什么？
Because we're moving on to episode two.
因为我们要继续看第二集。
I would just say that one thing that struck me watching the pilot was the sense memory of challenge of having to have Robin meet the rest of the gang.
我只想说，观看试播集时令我印象深刻的一件事是，必须让罗宾与其他团伙见面的挑战感记忆。
Robin, Kobe Smolder's only has scenes with Josh in the pilot.
科比·斯莫尔德的《罗宾》在试播集中只有乔什的镜头。
She never interacts with anybody else.
她从不与其他人交往。
And I remember that feeling at the end of the pilot, like we better have a good episode too that shows how she kind of works her way into this group and befriends this group because that's a whole other sale we have to make of like, she's the fifth banana.
我记得试播集结束时的感觉，就像我们最好也有一个好的剧集，展示她如何融入这个群体并与这个群体成为朋友，因为这是我们必须做的另一件事，她是第五根香蕉。
She's, you know, she's the, she's the fifth part of this five part puzzle.
她是，你知道，她是，她是这个五部分拼图的第五部分。
And we had to sort of integrate her and show how everybody else kind of fell in love with her two, and I had that feeling in my body.
我们必须将她融入其中，并向其他人展示如何爱上她两个，我的身体里就有这种感觉。
It's sort of re-experienced that we got to somehow thread the needle on it.
我们必须以某种方式把针穿在上面，这有点像是重新经历的。
I got to make the sale.
我必须完成销售。
I remember feeling that way when we had to write episode two and three, and that we're sort of showing her becoming part of that group, and yeah, it was just fun.
我记得当我们必须写第二集和第三集时有这种感觉，我们有点让她成为这个团体的一部分，是的，这很有趣。
Remember that challenge, and we'll rewatch and talk about if we did it.
记住这个挑战，我们会重新观看并讨论我们是否做到了。
I think we did.
我想我们做到了。
I think we pulled it off.
我想我们成功了。
I have two things.
我有两件事。
One is if you watch the pilot of how I made your mother, the DNA for the entire show is in the pilot.
一是，如果你观看《我如何造就你的母亲》的试播集，就会发现整个节目的 DNA 都在试播集中。
Yeah, like absolutely, the entire kind of structure and essence and surprise switcheroo kind of thing that they did so well.
是的，就像绝对一样，他们做得很好，整个结构和本质以及令人惊讶的转换之类的事情。
It's all, it's in there.
一切都在里面了。
It's like the ragu sauce or whatever.
就像拉古酱什么的。
It's like it's in there.
就好像它就在那里一样。
What people understand that you can cut that if they don't.
人们理解的内容，如果他们不理解，你可以削减它。
The other thing I wanted to say, this is just a funny anything that my wife said this morning, she was like, she knew someone who had who lived on the upper west side and he had a dog named Teddy and everyone called him the dog Teddy West side.
我想说的另一件事是，这只是我妻子今天早上说的一件有趣的事情，她就像，她认识一个住在上西区的人，他有一只名叫泰迪的狗，每个人都称他为狗泰迪西区。
And I love, as one of Ted's, he had so many nicknames.
作为特德的一员，我喜欢他有这么多的绰号。
Teddy West side's a great nickname.
泰迪西区是一个很棒的绰号。
I thought, but it was also self proclaimed, right?
我想，但这也是自称吧？
He called himself Teddy West.
他称自己为泰迪·韦斯特。
Yeah, I think it's trying to get everyone else on board.
是的，我认为它正在努力让其他人都加入进来。
They weren't on board.
他们不在船上。
Yeah.
是的。
She said, so where'd they live?
她说，那他们住在哪里？
And I said, they, they lives on the Upper West side, right?
我说，他们，他们住在上西区，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
And she said, but Robin lives in Brooklyn.
她说，但罗宾住在布鲁克林。
And I said, yeah.
我说，是的。
And she said, because Robin's cool, because we, like, Jordan, she grew up in Manhattan, but she lives in Brooklyn and she just can't stand going into Manhattan.
她说，因为罗宾很酷，因为我们，就像乔丹一样，她在曼哈顿长大，但她住在布鲁克林，她就是无法忍受去曼哈顿。
She loves Brooklyn.
她爱布鲁克林。
But she said, how was she hanging out on this bar on the Upper West side so much if she lived in Brooklyn?
但她说，如果她住在布鲁克林，怎么会经常去上西区的这个酒吧呢？
All the time.
一直以来。
Yeah, It's a shady commute.
是的，这是一个阴暗的通勤。
She would never.
她永远不会。
Oh, that's terrible.
哦，那太可怕了。
Here's what I rationalized.
这是我合理化的。
I think her TV station is close by.
我想她的电视台就在附近。
Yeah, let's say that.
是的，我们这么说吧。
TV stations in Midtown somewhere.
市中心某处的电视台。
So she's like, why not?
所以她想，为什么不呢？
Or even in the West 60s.
甚至在西方60年代也是如此。
Like where in the DCs?
比如DC的哪里？
Yes, the West 60s, like that sort of like CBS building, like West 50s, 60s, like that whole thing.
是的，西方 60 年代，就像 CBS 大楼那样，就像西方 50 年代、60 年代，就像整个事情一样。
So then she just pops up a couple of like 10 or 15 blocks and hangs out with her friend.
于是她就突然出现在 10 或 15 个街区之外，和她的朋友一起出去玩。
But also, she's out so late and she has to get up at like 3.30 in the morning to do the early.
而且，她出门这么晚，必须在凌晨 3.30 左右起床才能早起。
Just to take like an hour and a half.
只需要一个半小时左右。
These are the kind of threads we'll be pulling, that'll be.
这些就是我们将要拉动的线索。
Yeah, at some point she moves, but it's true.
是的，在某些时候她会移动，但这是事实。
For a while she had a real shit commute.
有一段时间，她的通勤经历真是糟糕透了。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
Olsen's off again.
奥尔森又下课了
New York City.
纽约市。
How we made your mother is hosted an executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯担任执行制片人主持。
The show was produced by me, Alec Webb.
该剧由我亚历克·韦伯制作。
And our co-producer is Doug Matka.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马特卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
Artwork by John Marrow.
约翰·马罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliott Connards.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《NYC》，特别感谢 Lola Kennedy 和 Elliott Connards。
Visit howwemadeyourmother.com to sign up for our substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 howwemadeyourmother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Rader's newsletters on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Rader 的时事通讯。
Read Craig Thomas' published prose at CraigThomasRider.com and you can subscribe to my dead father's society also on Substack.
阅读 Craig Thomas 在 CraigThomasRider.com 上发表的散文，您也可以在 Substack 上订阅我已故父亲的社团。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这展示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the Make It Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make It Difference”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of backyard ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持和 Tink Media 的营销支持下得以实现的。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
The real question.
真正的问题。
It just hit me.
它刚刚击中了我。
Am I in love with you or just new York City?
我爱的是你还是只爱纽约市？